president Trump sat down with North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un for a
productive meeting that offers some hope
for a denuclearized Korean Peninsula and
the world order but don't tell that to
hysterical theoreticians on the left and
right who threat and worry that even
though everything in reality is fine and
actually a little bit good in theory
everything is terrible we will analyze
the costs and benefits of the Kim summit
as well as the MSM spin-doctors who are
setting Donald Trump up to fail then
former White House press secretary Sean
Spicer stops by to shed some light on
those media spin doctors as well as the
White House's strategy for dealing with
them finally on this day in history no
coincidence another renegade American
president challenges a communist
dictator to give peace a chance
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
who knew I'm I think I'm a hippie now
I'm a hippie I I want to give peace a
chance and all of the Democrats don't
they want these to start exploding thing
like that that was also true during
Reagan's time and we will explain that
before we get to that we got to talk
about a little money honey we got to
make a little money honey and we're
gonna do that by talking about honey a
wonderful product that will save you
money and it's totally free go to join
honey calm slash cough FAC o VF e fe
honey is this absolutely phenomenal
browser extension which I have used for
years and years and saved a ton of money
using it is totally free you just takes
two clicks you add it to your browser it
saves you a ton of money it's ingenious
when you go shopping online honey will
just find you the best deals on
everything you're on Amazon it just
automatically finds you the cheapest
prices for whatever you want to buy on
Amazon it applies these discounts you
know in the old days you'd have to like
go searching and say where's a coupon
for whatever or store you know and then
you'd cycle through your trial the
coupons and they none of them would work
and then it would take you an hour and
come on your time is worth more than
that this is so good it magically adds
all sorts of useful info right onto the
Amazon page of whatever you're looking
at and you just shop like you normally
do it automatically searches the two
million sellers on Amazon finds you the
lowest price it even shows you the items
price changes so that you can decide if
you want to buy or if you want to wait
for it to come down a little bit when
honey's got your back you will never
overpay for anything on Amazon ever
again I actually can't tell you the last
time I used honey to buy something
because I couldn't tell you the last
time I didn't use honey to buy something
online I have used this consistently for
years every basically every purchase I
make on the Internet is with honey it's
so so good you'd be foolish not to add
it to your browser no reason not to do
it it is free takes two clicks to
install will make sure you always get
the lowest price on Amazon add honey for
free at join honey calm slash cough fa
CoV f EF e join honey dot-com slash
cough FAC o v f EF e okay lot to talk
about I don't know that I have ever seen
a diplomatic event receive stupider
press coverage and analysis in my entire
lifetime other than maybe do you
remember
the koi pond incident Donald Trump was
in Japan with Shinzo Abe a and he fed a
fish and then the media tried to make
this into some huge gaffe
even though Shinzo Abe a did the same
thing and so maybe other than that but
this is receiving really stupid coverage
on the left and the right and I don't
know for reaction to pundits coverage
before I give my analysis in in reaction
to this historic Trump Kim summit we
turn now to North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un and mr. Ahn you have been
watching CNN all morning what is your
take on the analysis that's a great
question that's actually my exact
reaction is well the big takeaway here
the the 30,000 foot view of this Kim
summit at Trump Kim summit in Singapore
is stop trying to make the first inning
into the ninth inning stop it stop
trying to make this into the final thing
like overnight we're gonna radically
change the world we're in the first
inning of this whole thing Secretary of
State Pompeyo is hashing things out
we've been negotiating with North Korea
for a very long time now really for
decades but under this administration
for months and months and months what
you take away from this summit is
broadly we are on track for a deal
that's a good thing that's the broad
scope a lot of things could have gone
wrong here imagine all of the things
that could have gone wrong that the
media would have harped on and said this
is the end of the world this is
humiliating for America and because none
of those things went wrong now they just
have to make stuff up here is what could
have gone wrong a Kim could have not
shown up that easily could have happened
right that would have been absolutely
humiliating right he could have he could
have stormed out he could have shown up
and then he could have stormed out like
when Trump called him fat which actually
happened we'll get to the clip of it
later
it is hilarious Trump called him fat in
public he could have stormed out right
there that would have been awful or Kim
could have gotten there and said we're
not gonna do nuclear eyes I got two
words for you Donald Trump and then
happy birthday
and that would have been truly
humiliating for the United States the
American president flies to this summit
and then Kim could have said we're not
going to denuclearize and Kim would have
had a lot of
leverage their right because he would
have been playing on this sort of Obama
paradigm of Obama was so desperate to
get any deal with America's adversaries
that he was willing to give them
everything in exchange and to be
humiliated
Iran captures our sailors Iran demands
we free up money in European banks Iran
demands a hundred billion dollars of
money flown over in an airplane he had a
lot of leverage here but it went very
well now what could have gone better
here because it didn't go per I'm not
saying this is some huge win this is a
world-changing win no this is a minor
win this is a step in the right
direction this is basically good but
it's not worth screaming and pulling
your hair right over and it's also not
worth jumping around in the streets to
be thrilled about it's just a good sign
that's okay we can smile that's nice
what could have gone better well a guess
we could have worked out a treaty
overnight for the immediate
denuclearization and an end to a 70 year
conflict overnight with no concessions
from the United States I guess that
would have been better what what are the
odds that that would have happened zero
that does not exist in reality no
negotiation would have let that happen
the the purpose of this meeting and you
wouldn't know this if you watch the
mainstream media but the purpose of this
meeting was to get some goodwill for
continued do negotiations to have the
two heads of state here meet one another
have Donald Trump feel the guy out Mike
Pompeo spelt this guy out and and that's
what we got we got this it all worked
out basically pretty well now don't pop
the champagne we haven't we don't have a
deal yet we've just got a good step in
the right direction anybody that was
expecting more than that anybody who was
expecting you know some overnight a
magical thing that would have gotten rid
of all of North Korea's nuke that
they've relied on for decades they were
trying to set up a narrative that Donald
Trump would fail that's what they were
trying to do right because that
obviously wasn't going to happen and so
when that didn't pan out they could have
said haha see we were right there is
there is so much bad analysis out there
about this meeting we'll try to get to
all of the objections and show why
they're so ridiculous but let's begin
with the main objection so the main
objection here
is that Western democratic statesman
would never meet with totalitarian
dictators how awful how terrible that
would be that's never happened before
this is totally unprecedented awful no
president has ever done this well except
for a ton of other world leaders from
Western democracies like Churchill and
Stalin Churchill met with Stalin okay
well okay but other than that M Nixon
and Mao Nixon went over and piled around
with Chairman Mao and other much more
murderous dictator than Kim jong-un and
they paled around and like played
ping-pong and swam around but other and
I'm sorry also Kennedy and Khrushchev so
Kennedy met with Khrushchev a maniacal
dictator of the Soviet Union who almost
blew up the entire world during the
Cuban Missile Crisis but other well and
okay also Donald Rumsfeld met with
Saddam Hussein then a special envoy to
the Middle East for Ronald Reagan
Rumsfeld met with Saddam Hussein another
murderous dictator who used WMD on his
own people but other than no really
except for Reagan and Gorbachev Reagan
meeting with Gorbachev before the
liberalizing policies of glasnost and
perestroika Reagan meeting with the
Soviet dictator a guy who you know
enslaved a gazillion people behind the
Iron Curtain and piled around and smiled
and shook his hand and slapped him on
the back okay so it actually happens all
the time okay
so I I'm sorry because I thought because
I watched CNN I thought this had never
happened this was totally unprecedented
this destroyed American credibility on
the world stage actually it happens all
the time so this is actually much more
of a no-brainer than any of those right
does anybody really believe that Kim
jong-un is on the same level of
wickedness as Stalin or Hitler or mal of
course not
of course no that's not to say Kim
jong-un is a good guy he's a miserable
awful vicious evil thug but as a matter
of scale even as a matter of ideology
there is not a chance that Kim is on the
same scale as Hitler right so what is it
the heart of hitlerism or of Stalinism
or you know that its expansion right so
a Hitler's plan was to conquer all of
these countries conquer all of this
territory expand expand expand the same
thing with the Soviet Union expand
expand expand
take over the whole world we're gonna
have this giant Empire the Soviet empire
what does Kim jong-un's plan is to
maintain his own little neighborhood
over there and in her third Korea to
keep his own little tin pot dictatorship
Kim is a gangster he's much more like
Castro than he is like Hitler
he's like Castro is a little dictator of
a Banana Republic and by the way Barack
Obama dealt with Castro remember Barack
Obama deals with Raul Castro everybody
says this is wonderful and in that
negotiation Obama gave Castro everything
in exchange for nothing gave him
everything said American tourists can
come here even though I can't get the
sanctions repealed from Congress I'm
gonna make it much much easier for
Americans to spend money there I'm going
to practically stop enforcing sanctions
against Cuba the Cuban embargo act that
when Donald Trump deals with Kim jong-un
he gives him basically nothing nothing
yet Donald Trump gives Kim basically
nothing yet and that yet is where the
negotiations come in so lefties and
Trump critics on the right are spinning
this summit as this huge loss for
America this huge win for North Korea
this we shouldn't pay that really much
attention because we knew they would do
this right the Sean Spicer was talking
about this yesterday and we'll have him
on later we're going to talk with Sean
Spicer he's coming up but he was talking
about this yesterday said there's no bar
that Donald Trump could reach that would
get mainstream media approval for this
summit they'll find something wrong in
the handshake or what he says or a joke
that he made or right and that's exactly
what is playing out but it gets so much
crazier than this you've got to hear
some of the hysteria that is coming out
of the mainstream media and we will
explain why it gets to the central
premise of the left and why basically
everybody is reacting stupidly to the
summit before we do that we got to talk
about man crates baby we got a Father's
Day is coming up and you know this this
is the problem with Father's Day every
year is your dad won't tell you what he
wants right so you're gonna say hey dad
what do you what do you want for
Father's Day he'll say
don't get don't get me anything right
that's always like don't get me anything
cuz then especially if it's a you know
if you're a younger child because he's
the father's thinking like let's just my
money right you know here's a don't but
if you're when you're an adult even
they'll say now don't get me anything
and then you don't get him anything and
then he's angry and sad right because
he's your father don't worry about that
anymore he doesn't want to tie he
doesn't want right what he wants is a
very cool gift experience called man
crates so give him a gift he's
guaranteed to loved it's handpicked and
packaged gifts for every type of debt
there's the knife making kit for the
hands-on dad or the whiskey appreciation
crate for fathers who like the finer
things and by the way if someday my
children are looking back on this and
you know they're watching a rerun of of
my show I want the whiskey appreciation
crate that's the one I want that's the
good I actually got one it's so good I
used the the decanter all the time it's
got a really cool whiskey glasses great
ice cubes spherical ice cube makers
really really good most gives ship in a
wooden sealed crate with a crowbar so he
can pry open his man crate in front of
everyone when was the last time you gave
your dad a gift that he needed a crowbar
to open with man crates you're giving
dad more than a gift you're giving him
experience like any other I really think
this about gifts most people have stuff
we have a ton of stuff in America and
2018 you don't really need any stuff but
a gift is about the giving and the
experience of giving in the relationship
and what that represents and man crates
is a wonderful experience get your a
special Father's Day discount today with
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
at man crates calm / knowles K&O wles
this is a limited time offer only for
Father's Day which is coming up folks so
go today man crates calm / Knowles Keo
wles
man crates calm / Knowles alright so
back to the media hysteria over this
summit so Brent you douse key writing in
the hill he says this is the headline
Trump let Kim get away with murder all
right how's it gonna go on from there
this really writes quote Trump is now a
danger to the democratic alliance by the
way I thought he was a danger after net
neutrality and tax reform no way isn't
that the big day
that was gonna kill us all okay but now
I guess now it's super serious now he's
a danger to the democrat alliance Bude
ascii goes on quote he is the only
president in American history who treats
America's friends like enemies and its
enemies like friends until except the
last President Obama who treated our
allies in Israel like enemies and our
enemies in Iran like friends exactly and
and oh and a lot of statesmen deal with
adversaries with both diplomacy and with
strong-arm tactics this you know it
basically every claim he makes is not
true statesman regularly meet with
dictators this guy is upset that Donald
Trump was mean to Justin Trudeau of
Canada and it's funny we talked about
Trudeau yesterday and how he's like a
little whiny little boy people forget
that Ronald Reagan was also mean to the
last Trudeau of Canada because obviously
little boy Justin Trudeau is he got his
position through nepotism his father
Pierre Trudeau was a former leader of
Canada and Reagan didn't like him either
because I don't like these whiny left
you know they're just not enjoyable
people to deal with
so okay I guess they forgot about that
here is some mainstream media analysis
and build-up to show you exactly what I
mean the optics are very significant and
as you know a lot of analysts have
suggested this is already a public
relations win for North Korea because
the North Korean leader is being
well-received on the international stage
right now is it already a win for kim
jungeun and that that's a big win for
him regardless of what comes out of this
summit him on the world stage in a way
that no leader from North Korea has ever
been I think this is a huge win in terms
of respect legitimacy so this is really
funny isn't it this is they say hey
regardless of what happens this is going
to be a loss for Donald Trump well how
do you know that you know there's a
transparent in trying to set up Trump to
fail they say no matter what happens
he's gonna lose right okay okay can we
all agree on that like I know he could
lose if you know Kim storms out or
insults the United States on the world
stage but he could win right it could be
a sort of win and this is also funny
because you'll remember the Olympics
which it happened five minutes ago do
you remember
during those Olympics in Korea how the
left loved putting the Kim family on the
world stage
because their argument now is if you put
Kim in the spotlight and you put him
next to American leaders then that's
gonna be bad that's gonna be really bad
except for five minutes ago when it was
great when that dragon lady became the
breakout star of the Winter Olympics
around he said oh she stole the show
she's the breakout store Oh but that was
when it was the Olympics that was one it
was a left-wing thing doing it now that
Donald Trump's doing it it's bad do you
follow that logic and by the way what's
gonna happen now is the left is gonna
say well sure okay that was hypocritical
but now conservatives are hypocritical
to enjoy this summit not true not true
at all the Olympics was the left
cheering on brutal dictators despite
Donald Trump this summit is
conservatives dealing in diplomatic
flattery in the hopes of peace after all
of the other strategies that we have
tried for several decades have failed
that's what this is a that is a huge
difference all of the other strategies
have failed and this one offers at least
sort of hope for a victory
so you remember also about six seven
months ago when Donald Trump was
threatening war the mainstream media
said it was horrible remember he was
saying my button is bigger than your
button I've got fire and fury and
nuclear weapons that I could write and
they said that's awful that's gonna lead
to World War 3 now Donald Trump is doing
the opposite he's pursuing diplomacy the
media you know what they're saying
you're gonna be shocked to hear this
they're saying it's horrible
you're saying it's awful it's kind of
it's weird it's like he's kind of damned
if he doesn't damn it if he doesn't the
real answer of course is that we have to
do both we need to have credibility and
the credible threat of violence and we
have to pursue diplomacy the media are
reporting that this is a big win for Kim
this is the huge win what did he win ask
yourself that because they're all gonna
report that that's gonna be the headline
this was a huge win for Kim okay what
did he win did the United States lift
the economic sanctions no we have some
of the stiffest sanctions in place that
we've ever had against North Korea
that's the main leverage that's actually
what's at issue this negotiation is
between nuclear weapons and economic
sanctions that's what it is you get to
you can either have a gigantic nuclear
arsenal
or you can participate in global trade
that that's it and right and that's
basically we're trying to get the North
Koreans to give up the weapons in
exchange for participating in the
international community we we still have
all the sanctions in place all of that
leverage is in place that's why it's not
like the Iran deal now what what else
did he win he got publicity on the world
stage Kim gets plenty of publicity on
the world stage all by his himself
that's totally fine he already got a
legitimacy by the way on the world stage
from April's Panmunjeom declaration in
South Korea that was when they went a
couple months ago to South Korea and
declared they're gonna pursue
denuclearization and an end to the
Korean War so he's already got that
legitimacy on the world stage that's
that's been building for a long time so
what else did he get he got a handshake
and some flattering words from Donald
Trump by the way I don't know if you've
watched a clips of Donald Trump over the
past four decades but he can be a little
hot or cold you know if you're nice to
him and he's getting what he wants he
can be effusive he can be over-the-top
flattering and then the minute you turn
on him he's just knifes you in the back
and he kind of goes back and forth
because that's what he does because he's
a New Yorker and he's a real-estate guy
you know that's how he talks I don't
think people put a whole lot of stock
and some flattering words from Donald
Trump yeah and also American leaders
have always shaken hands with murderous
dictators in fact this goes all the way
back to the founding of the country
Thomas Jefferson and John Adams made
nice with the Barbary pirates who were
enslaving our sailors basically at the
foundation of our country they made nice
they said nice words to them they made
concessions to them right this has been
going on since the very beginning so
what did Donald Trump say Donald Trump
said Kim is talented this is obviously
true it's sort of damning with faint
praise because Kim's talent is it
enslaving his own people and murdering
his all of his opponents but it's
obviously true you know the guy took
power at age 26 and managed to keep hold
over this bizarro world communist
dictatorship long after communism was
relegated to the ash heap of history but
also what else did Donald Trump say
about Kim seven months ago he called him
short and fat he sent out that tweet he
said oh I would never call Kim jong-un
and fat actually by the way Donald Trump
called Kim jong-un fat in the room at
this summit listen to this and then
watch the look on Kim Jong Un's face of
you who weren't watching you got a look
at Kim jong-un's face in this because he
says you know yeah we're gonna we got to
look really thin really nice you know
the camera pans over and and Kim jong-un
looks there like Larry David you just
kind of sees it we're gonna look really
thin and it goes over your like bum that
is really a perfect perfect way to start
to because it's not just an offhanded
thing that's a little dig that's a very
Trumpy very New York little dig to say
who's boss here right
oh we're gonna look hey we got a you've
got to work pretty hard to make us look
thin okay huh hey you you get it don't
you Kimmy you get it little one I don't
know what is it one ear so whatever Kim
Jong Un's nickname is maybe probably
doesn't have a nickname now okay the big
concession that is being reported here
is that Donald Trump said that he would
cancel a joint military exercise with
South Korea as a concession toward
denuclearization and everyone's freaking
out they say Oh South Korea didn't know
about this by the way South Korea issued
the president of South Korea issued a
statement talking about how wonderful
this summit was how great Donald Trump
did so you know those headlines take
them with less than a grain of salt but
also the point that everybody is missing
here is that the war game that's being
talked about isn't scheduled to happen
for a full year the the joint military
exercise that's been canceled isn't
scheduled to happen for a year by the
way you'll you'll recall another big
event in Korea was recently cancelled
and then it wasn't cancelled the summit
that he said that at right this isn't
dumb Trump said the summits canceled too
bad it's over and then a couple days
later Kim comes back to the table he
says okay it's back on this is obviously
just a negotiating tactic
he's obviously saying
look we're gonna we're gonna try to not
have to have this military exercise but
then he later said in that same
discussion right he says look in six
months we'll see if Kim does what he
says he's gonna do if not I'm gonna have
to say something else I'm gonna have to
change my mind
he told a joke he's like he says I'm
gonna I'm gonna come up with an excuse
to explain it or something but what he's
signaling there is okay in a year I sure
would like it if we don't need that
joint military exercise because by the
way we only need these provocative
exercises if North Korea is provoking us
and saying they're gonna blow up the
world of nuclear weapons that's why we
have to show them that we've still got
giant planes that can blow them to
smithereens also by the way this
handshake did not come cost-free to
North Korea they're saying oh well it
put him on the world stage with the
president and that you know that's a big
propaganda win I don't know maybe I mean
he's already been elevated to these
levels of running a country he does run
his own country right but this handshake
does it come cost-free information is
very tightly controlled into and out of
North Korea now we have images of Kim
jong-un palying around with Donald Trump
talking about friendship between him and
Donald Trump a new era we're gonna let
the past be the past that undoes a lot
of North Korean propaganda there's been
propaganda throughout North Korea for
the past 70 years about how America's
the evil this evil country and we're
gonna come we're still at war
they're the enemy they're unhuman human
and now you see this picture and they're
piling around right and Donald Trump is
the big guy in the room just physically
is this a giant guy compared to short
fat little rocket man he's smiling he's
calling Kim fat in the room it's hard to
undo those images too it's hard to undo
those images and those cut against a lot
of North Korean propaganda so even that
which is the only possible win that the
North Korea could say they got here even
that is a double-edged sword and but
this is the big lefty argument right the
big lefty argument is optics they say oh
the optics just didn't look good I don't
know why they didn't look good only the
optics of Donald Trump standing there
with it didn't look good and this is my
central argument about the left they the
left cares about the
appearance of the thing rather than the
thing itself so you know they say who
cares if it works in practice does it
work in theory right that's that's their
argument
bad optics bad optics for whom who was
as bad optics for this is another
central premise of bad optics right it's
this prejudice of the left the left
thinks oh we would never be duped
because we're smart people but those
rube idiot masses they can be duped by
optics that's the that's the premise and
that's the prejudice this oh it's bad
optics what do you mean what are you
saying bad optics what you're saying is
it's not actually bad but it looks bad
to stupid people right everybody else is
so much stupider than we we blessed few
in the media you know and that's why the
bad optics matter that's totally wrong
in in real life the actual people who
get fooled by optics are precisely the
people who worry about those optics so
much of the time in the mainstream media
this is why Donald Trump communicates so
well right people understand what Donald
Trump means in the mainstream media
worried about the optics all the
theoreticians they worry about the
optics you know Donald Trump announced
his presidency or his presidential
campaign he said Mexico sending
criminals over the border now the
mainstream media the never Trump
movement they all worried they said all
the optics people said what was wrong
with what Trump said he said well it's
not that it was wrong exactly it's that
the optics were bad when people knew
what he meant
Americans knew what he meant they are
sending criminals across the border not
everybody's a criminal no but they are
they're a lot of grip crime comes across
the border from Mexico first of all by
definition illegal immigration is a
crime also a ton of drugs also a ton of
gang members also ms-13
speaking of ms-13 that animals remark he
said ms-13 they're animals and they said
oh the optics oh the OP it sounds like
he's calling immigrants animals no it
does him he didn't say that
but it's maybe idiots would think that
right with your but you mainstream media
you were the idiots you were the people
are not the idiots you are the idiots
and finally the the final before because
we'll have to move on we gotta get you
on Spicer on the final stupid media
narrative here is that this was reckless
impulsive it was driven by ego and
narcissus
some is reckless what was he doing
Donald Trump has been explaining this
for decades he's been talking about
doing this for decades here's Donald
Trump explaining precisely what happened
in 1999 North Korea is totally out of
control and would you rather have a very
very serious chat with them now and if
necessary you might have to do something
fairly drastic or would you rather have
to go after them in five years when they
have more nuclear warheads and missiles
than we do you go and you start
negotiating and if you don't stop them
from that you will have to take rather
drastic actions because if you don't
take them now you're gonna be an awfully
big trouble in five years from now when
they have more missiles than we do we're
a bunch of SAP's what if they're North
Koreans don't play ball develop a
nuclear capability go forward with their
missile development does the United
States act unilateral excuse me if if
spoken to correctly correctly they will
play ball look on another front what
happened recently where Clinton has
asked our trade our so-called trade
partners to come so we can renegotiate
some fairness into trade right they
don't show up they say we're not coming
why would Germany show up why would
France show up why would Japan show up
they've been ripping this off for years
so why would they come here it's
ridiculous it's it's interesting that
these old clips do shed a lot of light
on Donald Trump's thinking because he's
thinking about this essentially he
pivots at the end he's just talking
about trade right it goes from talking
about Karina talking about trade because
he views these things as trade
negotiations as business negotiations
and this is Donald Trump's strengths
first of all what else are we gonna do
right these other strategies haven't
worked so why not give this a shot
what's the loss the loss is nothing that
Kim doesn't basically already have and
nothing that can't be revoked but this
is Donald Trump's strength Donald Trump
negotiates with the worst people on
earth right the idea to not meet with
Kim is was one of fear oh I fear what if
this mate lead to this optic and that
doesn't just do it just do it just do it
now and then if that doesn't work we'll
do something else okay just don't be
afraid
stop being so fearful and just try
something but this is Trump's strength
he negotiates with the worst people on
earth these real estate guys in new
or mobsters literally mobsters if you
want to do New York real estate you have
to talk to the mob and certainly did in
the 70s and 80s before Rudy Giuliani
Donald Trump's lawyer cracked the mob in
New York a reality television I mean TV
those people are trust me I see them all
the time in Hollywood they're like the
worst people on earth and politics right
so he deals with these people and he's
negotiating in a way that you would talk
to thugs in the way that you would talk
to gangsters and that's what literal
gangsters are in New York real estate
and it's what Kim jong-un is he's a
gangster and Trump is talking to him
like a gangster and we'll see what comes
from it it's it's a it's a certainly a
step in the right direction to call it
an amazing win is obviously premature
and to say that this is possibly the end
of the world is also clearly wrong this
was a step in the right direction if it
goes in the wrong direction we'll pull
it back nothing lost those sanctions are
still in place we still have the
position of strength we got a break Sean
Spicer on to talk about all this
ridiculous media spin I spoke with Sean
last night we're going to have him after
the break but I'm sorry if you're on
Facebook and YouTube sorry guys I don't
know what to tell you you got to go to
daily wire calm right now daily wire.com
you subscribe it's $10 a month $100 for
an annual membership you get me at the
end reclaim ensure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag everybody can watch a
mailbag but only subscribers can ask the
questions many are called but few are
chosen and also today we're gonna we got
a great show coming up later on today
it's gonna be a Father's Day special
broadcast on The Daily wire it's gonna
be the big boss Ben Shapiro Andrew
Klavan leader of the multiverse myself
we're gonna have zou Rachel a longtime
friend of all of us and of the show and
international television and film star
Nick Searcy Peabody award-winning we're
gonna be all be there hanging around
smoking cigars drinking scotch and
talking about the importance of
fatherhood
that's gonna be on later today be sure
to tune in for that okay we're gonna
bring on Sean Spicer then we'll tie this
all back together on this day in history
but we'll be right back
[Music]
okay so I talked to Sean yesterday Sean
Spicer really cool guy former spokesman
for the president White House press
secretary he's got a new book coming out
called the briefing and I usually read
the book before the interview the book
it really is not out yet I don't have an
advanced copy of it it's coming out next
month but talking to sure I've talked to
Sean about what's in the book it sounds
really interesting I can't wait to read
it by the way that Father's Day special
is gonna be at 4 p.m. Pacific today and
7 p.m. eastern be sure to tune in for
that
and here we here's our talk with Sean
Spicer Sean thank you for being here
thanks for having me so you had the
hardest job on planet Earth
a White House press secretary spokesman
for the president United States how
would you rate your tenure at the White
House you can be a letter grade
numerical siskel and ebert thumbs up how
do you think that you did looking back
on it now I you know I I think that
considering the nature of Trump's
presidency that he was a disrupter that
this is a guy he didn't come at this
with a group of political loyalists that
a lot of people have had in the past I
think we did really well when you look
at what we accomplished in the first six
months and the groundwork that that laid
to things like tax reform you know I
think it really was a disruptive time
but it also was a productive time
absolutely I certainly agree with that
can you take us behind the scenes a
little bit I've always wondered about
that job more than the chief of staff
more than even the president what it is
like in that pressure cooker for the
press secretary what does a typical day
look like it's a great question because
I think there's a question of what does
the job normally look like and what does
it look like under a trump
administration because one of the things
that I did is really speak to a lot of
my predecessors and try to understand
the battle rhythm of the day what
happens the the process that they all
enjoyed that was vastly different under
Trump because you know for the most part
throughout my career and throughout the
career of most press people you're
advising the principal as far as what to
say when to say it and you know even
what platform to use with Trump he's
pretty much the lead on a lot of those
things
that's a very different dynamic and when
it came to the briefing
obviously the intensity in scrutiny
during the Trump administration was
vastly different than it has been under
any previous administration and so the
job in itself is very very different
than then than it was in the past and
part of the you know you mentioned the
book earlier I I walked through a
day-in-the-life what I used to be like
to get ready every day and the only way
to really you know the short end of it
it was like getting ready for a final
exam every day well you know I I really
look forward to reading it I you always
try to read the book before the
interview but I don't have a copy yet so
I'm eagerly looking forward because it
sounds really good and I agree obviously
the Trump administration is just a
different beast than these previous
administrations I thought you handled
yourself wonderfully I was a big
cheerleader of Sean Spicer and Sean
Spicer universe one I knew there was one
out there yes funny
yeah can I tell you a funny story that
you you just brought that up I'm on I've
been at an event for my son in the last
hour so and I walked in and one of the
other parents said gosh that tweet you
put out about Trudeau was hysterical and
I said are you being serious because you
know that's not me right and they were
like what do you mean that's like you're
following a parody account that is a lot
of people will see those tweets all the
time and I think the reason the parody
works so well is it because the account
of Sean's spicier or the you know the
the spicier version it actually does
channel a lot of that spirit you brought
to it
I mean you I actually always I always
felt you were I feel you were far kinder
to those blood sucking leeches in the
media then they deserved it all I
thought you know you handled him very
well do you have any regrets about them
I found they would always try to gin up
these fake gaffes about you like you
know you were lost in the bushes or
something or you made a completely
accurate statement about the number of
people who viewed the inauguration and
they would pretend like you were saying
these crazy things do you have regrets
about that you wish you a
I don't know been harder on them or
something well there's a lot of
interactions that that I've had you know
whether it's personal or professional
when I look back and say you know could
I have been better at that and I think
just because there you know it's it's a
lot of the advice that I look back on
with stuff that you know most of our
moms teach us right two wrongs don't
make a right just because they said it
doesn't mean you do - and and and so
there were times when I think I probably
let them get a let them get the better
of me once in a while or I we escalated
too quickly but you're right I mean
there were times when I looked at and I
thought to myself wait a second the job
of the press secretary is to speak on
behalf of the president of the
administration the American people and
it was too often that I had to talk
about myself and that's that's not a
good place to be as a press person right
and well this gets to a real question
because there seems to be this media
crack-up in the last few years in the
old days the network's dominated
Republicans had to play with these guys
even though they were quite hostile now
we have all these other outlets we have
Twitter we have live streaming you've
been in Republican communications for a
long time but you know people know you
primarily as the press secretary you
were communications director for the RNC
House Budget Committee chief strategist
of the RNC you've known them for a long
time this question has two parts should
Republicans still talk to outlets that
are hostile to them the New York Times
or should we tell these lefty
mouthpieces to go pound sand and second
are there any good journalists that you
would still recommend these guys are
doing hard work they're not just
partisan hacks - great questions on the
first one yes we should talk to them
because you don't seed ground you don't
grow the audience you don't allow people
to hear conservative ideas if you ignore
them I believe just like you know that
if you look at what what the church does
in terms of missionaries the idea is to
go out there and to spread the good news
and I think if you are a social and
fiscal conservative then part of what
you want to do is go out there and
explain to people because what happens
more than anything is a lot of these
Main Street outlets either you know
cover conservatives in a very nasty way
or don't cover issues of importance and
so by being out there it allows people
who might be what
so hey I never thought of that issue in
that way or I never knew that I shared
the views of you know a particular
person might be espousing them on a
policy or what-have-you and so I think
it's a great way to grow the movement
and secondly yeah there are a lot of
great reporters in that briefing room
and you know the interesting thing is
and I actually have a part in the book
where I talk about this where there are
some really good reporters at a lot of
reputable outlets it's not it's not
always just the broad brush the
Washington Post New York Times or
whatever there are good reporters at a
lot of these institutions and what I
want to do is make sure that we call
balls and strikes better that we call
out the bad reporters and then we praise
the good ones because when we just say
fake news or the New York Times is
horrible then we we sort of dismiss the
ones that are actually doing a decent
job and I think what what has really
killed things is two things one is
social media where reporters almost
acted as if people don't have Twitter
accounts themselves because they express
these opinions and things that really
expose their liberal bias and second is
the need for a lot of these reporters to
get on television will make them say and
do outrageous things to sort of get
themselves booked that makes perfect
sense that that you know that the
sensationalism of it obviously not every
reporter is just Jim Acosta who I
believe is played by Will Ferrell these
days on television that you know there
are there are people at these outlets
who aren't just the editors they're all
are doing work and I agree I think it
might be something about our Catholicism
that we just are perfectly willing to
talk to anybody go into the belly of the
beast
but I have taken too much of your time
you got to run you are you're with your
family right now that's another thank
you you know the funny thing is after
reading your book I really felt inspired
you know people ask me all the time why
do I want to write a book and I just
felt your book really laid out a lot of
the policies but I think we're so key to
the Democrats current state of being
that I just needed to kind of put my
thoughts to paper but I I think it was
it was a lot more writing than and you
probably did well perhaps although I did
a lot of research and I will say Shawn I
always knew you were
I always knew
were a gentleman but now I know that
you're a scholar as well so I look
forward to reading yours there were a
couple at some point we have more time I
want to debate a couple of the issues
that you raised in there right around
the 200 page mark I thought you got into
some pretty meaty stuff it does it's an
esoteric reading too so what will really
have to go into the different layers
that we have there but I suppose that'll
be for a future episode John thank you
so much for being here I really
appreciate it and they'll talk to you
next time you bet thank you god I love
that guy
so the book by the way is the briefing I
look forward to reading it I've got a
pre-order and it's gonna be great I'm
sure because Sean Spicer was there at
the moment you know at this moment of
this colossal new administration coming
in and he dealt with the press really
really well my you know it's funny
because a lot of people criticize him
for being too harsh on the press I think
he was far too nice to them I thought he
did a really good job look forward to
reading the book before I let you go we
only have a couple minutes here at the
end I do want to point out something on
this day in history related to this kin
summit because people aren't drawing the
connection and it's because as with so
many things that come around with Donald
Trump they're looking just at the
surface level and they're not seeing all
the little jokes and all of the little
coincidences that happen underneath it
so let's get to this day in history
on this day in history in 1987 Ronald
Reagan went to Berlin and gave a very
famous speech to a Soviet dictator
Mickey Gorbachev to tear down this wall
the Kim summit took place on the same
day now it seems like it was yesterday
because you know it was in Singapore and
we're here in the United States but if
this was June 12th
so the Kim summit took place on June
12th tear down this wall took place on
June 12th this could be a coincidence
but it's a pretty big coincidence and
you've got to remember the people around
Donald Trump the people setting up this
summit with a North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un these are pretty sophisticated
people who have been around politics for
a very long time now I think Donald
Trump is pretty smart as well but a lot
of people they say oh he's a dummy he's
a dummy they don't they fail to realize
by the way that all the really
successful presidents have played
dummies Ronald Reagan did it
Bill Clinton actually did it George Bush
did it they forget that part but even if
you think that Donald Trump is a dummy
all the people around him are pretty
sophisticated Mike Pompeo john bolton
these are guys who were around during
the reagan years and i it's really hard
for me to believe that that is a
coincidence
and it's by the way both of those
speeches but the summit and the tear
down this wall speech were about the
exact same thing it was an appeal to
renew arms reduction talks here is
ronald reagan at the berlin wall there
is one sign that the soviets can make
that would be unmistakable that would
advance Drennen become dramatically the
cause of freedom and peace general
secretary Gorbachev if you seek peace if
you seek prosperity for the Soviet Union
and Eastern Europe if you seek
liberalization come here to this gate
mr. Gorbachev open this gate
mr. Gorbachev mr. Gorbachev tear down
this wall
what a speech and a line written by the
way I think by Peter Robinson who also
has the great show uncommon knowledge a
tear down this wall Ronald Reagan
applies two techniques here he's harsh
they're right tear down this wall tear
down this wall
he's also nice even if you seek peace
and he was nice to Gorbachev he would
flatter him he would shake his hand he
would Pat his back
here's just a little clip I pulled up on
the Internet of Ronald Reagan flattering
dear old Gorby and the significance of
that today we are commemorating an event
that is highly symbolic Ronald Reagan
and Mikhail Gorbachev shook hands on the
step you see behind you it had all
started right here with a handshake that
changed history they shook hands this is
you know when we look back at history we
sometimes remember it in a very
distorted way we just remember Reagan
bearing down tear down this Walter but
there was also the the friendliness to
mickey gorbachev we just remember him
saying we're gonna build up Star Wars
SDI we're gonna run you out of the arms
race right we forget that Ronald Reagan
was begging for the abolition of nuclear
weapons with the leader of the Soviet
Union stormed out of a meeting because
they couldn't abolish nuclear weapons
there are two sides of this and there
have to be two sides to these
negotiations the harsh the credible
threat of violence the tough-guy
and the the diplomatic niceties and the
diplomatic flattery and the handshaking
in the back patting so far that's what
we're getting out of this that's a good
day that's a win might all go wrong
tomorrow and then in six months Trump is
gonna come up and say it was all wrong
it's gonna be all over again but for
today this is a this is a good move in
the right direction and we should be
happy about it
not thrilled not poppin champagne just
happy it's a good step in the right
direction take yes for an answer people
come on okay we've got some really crazy
shows coming up this week I don't want
to ruin it for you but we decided my
first week after the honeymoon is just
gonna be this insane week it's gonna be
pretty wild so be sure to tune in
tomorrow and through the rest of the
week in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show get your
mailbag questions and for Thursday I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you